we are being replaced in this country by
Third World Invaders criminal illegal
alien Invaders and unfortunately what's
happening is when these illegals are
coming to places like Texas you have
Governors like Governor Abbott who are
then putting them on buses and I I had
um you know one of my uh followers on X
sent me a video that they filmed of a
bus of these illegals with Texas plates
getting dropped off at a uh train
station just outside of Chicago why does
that matter well people may think oh
it's all fun and games you know hahaa
give these Democrats a taste of their
own medicine by shipping them to
Sanctuary cities but these are cities
where they give illegals driver licenses
and so these people are going to have
IDs and what's going to stop them not
that we really have voter ID in this
country anyway but uh what's going to
stop these people from voting in our
election but that's not the issue vote
I'm I'm not I'm not concerned in the
immediate with the idea that illegal
immigrant votes the issue is simply by
being here it gives Democrats more
congressional seats and more electoral
votes